liberal media pundits melting down in
spectacular fashion over the stunning
upset in virginia and blaming democrat
losses on americans being racist
some of it was
uh dog whistle racism
it's essentially white identity politics
that works for republicans education
right which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching about race the real ominous
thing
is that
critical race theory
which isn't real
turned the suburbs
15 points
to the trump insurrection endorsed
republican the delta variant of trumpism
in other words duncan
same disease but spreads a lot faster
and can get a lot more places
while the media is calling voters racist
what they aren't mentioning is
republican winsome sears winning in
virginia's lieutenant governor's race
the first woman of color to win that
particular office in the state's history
all right jesse i'm going to start with
you okay i just heard that quote from
nicole wallace i think the real ominous
thing is the critical race theory which
isn't real turned the suburbs 15 points
to trump insurrection endorsed
republicans what are they talking about
well judge as a journalist
we hunted down the curriculum on the
internet and the receipts they paid to
consultants and when i say we i mean my
assistant did so she should be able to
do the same
this is an analogy permission yes
granted maybe the guys would understand
this more than the women uh-oh
is this about arousal again no no
geraldo you sicko that's what greg's you
know when you go out drinking with a
buddy and then you come back from the
bar you look in the mirror to check
yourself out and you realize your flies
down
and you think to yourself why didn't my
buddy tell me my flaw was down maybe
he's not a good friend right
and that is the relationship the media
has with the democrats if the media
really
wanted the democrats to do well they say
hey democrats you might want to fix that
crt thing it's causing a little issue
but they don't do that now do i want the
media to wake the democrats up to this
woke disaster no
donald trump said it everything woke
turns to what judge i won't let you
finish that family show i'll let you
finish so
here's what's going to happen now
these pundits that are getting paid
millions of dollars they're saying this
is about race well how could it be this
is a virginia state that voted for
barack obama twice
yunkan won hispanics 55 percent
he won white 60
he doubled trump's numbers with black
women that is what they call a rainbow
coalition this wasn't a base election
this is in a blue state that he won
independence by almost 10. terry didn't
listen to the women terry called the
women the moms domestic terrorists and
racists now even i know judge you don't
talk to women like that you listen to
women like yunkan did who told him that
they didn't want racism taught in the
classroom and that's why he capitalized
on that barack obama told women
no your feelings don't count
they're phony
and then terry mcauliffe told women you
know doesn't matter what they're
injecting into your child's brains you
don't have anything to do with that all
right that's what happened and that's
why this backlash is happening and if
the media keeps just not telling the
democrats what's really going on there's
going to be bloodbath after bloodbath
thank you for the zipper ideology well
so i will go right to you dana all right
winsome sears
she has made history an african-american
lieutenant governor a heartbeat away
from the governor in the commonwealth of
virginia she resists the crt and that
whole progressive doctrine she's she's
amazing and she has an incredible name
uh she will be it's one that you will
definitely remember it'll be fun to
watch her career i'm going to defend the
media some in the media for a moment
they did try to tell them do you
remember that viral video when terry
mcauliffe shut down the reporter
and he took off his microphone and said
i'm done well the reason is because the
reporter was asking about education in
schools and terry mcauliffe said
why don't you ask about things that
virginians really care about they tried
to warn him julie weil of the washington
post she went out she talked to actual
people and there was an african-american
dad that she interviewed who said i
started homeschooling because i didn't
like the assignments that were coming
home a hispanic mother who said i'm
worried that this race curriculum is
going to lead to my child being bullied
so it to me they just had the blinders
on and they wanted to believe that
president trump and antagonism towards
him was going to deliver them to a win
and that obviously didn't happen okay
geroldo kind of a rainbow coalition
across the country from new york new
jersey texas seattle uh don't overstate
it though judge oh no
told somebody not to overstate it
your career yeah is overstating i think
the commentators like democrats
generally are whiny they're annoying uh
they when you i watched you know i hate
hate watches at what jesse calls it uh
cnn msnbc i watched everybody with the
sound off and the democrat i mean the
the other networks were so gloomy they
were so depressed they were big frowns
and even everything looked blue and
black and and and and you know very very
depressed it was
this is not that big a deal
in my town in cleveland the young
progressive beat uh the the old line
democrat in the runoff for the cleveland
mayor uh and the issue 24 which would uh
basically defund cops and create a
civilian review board uh passed
overwhelmingly despite the opposition
for me and my radio show and and other
people who are more in the middle or or
to the right so my point is that this is
not the great tidal wave and these media
people are over here what happened in
buffalo the write-in beat the socialist
but the write-in beat the song that's my
point but the guy who the write-in guy
was a middle-of-the-road guy he wasn't a
right geraldo they rejected to fund the
police yeah they did long island
republicans swept boston nassau counties
come on texas austin texas they had a
proposition to increase the police force
it was defeated that's one kooky
proposition
i'm talking new jersey you know what
greg i want you to settle this whole
thing all right i got a few comments
number one nicole wallace says crt
doesn't exist but wmd did
she's ignorant and lazy the data was
there uh chris ruffo did a tremendous
job brianna keeler she went from eating
crickets to eating crow she keeps
additionally chowing down desiccated
rodents uh what's her name kirsten
powers was on there she just she's
putting in a book about grace about how
to treat people better while she brands
a million people is racist because of
the way they vote how can you speak of
grace when you smear so many people god
isn't pleased with you kirsten god is
not pleased they're all racist right
brianna nicole kirsten joy reid because
they ignored sears the first black woman
the first woman of color to win a
statewide election in virginia why
because she dared to leave the the
plantation of ideology that these white
women and joy reid believe she should
stay on they are the racist but i have
to give props to one person there was
one person in the media thank you over
what no you're close you're close one
person in the middle
yeah it might be you you're close
there's one person in the media that 10
days ago predicted the outcome of this
race for a very specific reason and i
believe we have tape
can i make a prediction i think the
republican is going to win in virginia
and you want to know why why his name is
young kin
and it's about
young kin young kin huh
i love it wow that's exactly why
that's why it's getting a bold
prediction yes what a way to wrap up the
segment i know thank you but you didn't
bet heraldo did you no no no i'm very uh
all right people with my money coming up
come on why don't you fire it in the air
what is this yeah well we don't know
what it was but
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else